primary voters in two potential
battleground states why waited for hours
rather to vote yesterday and a possible
preview of the November election Nevada
limited in-person voting to a small
number stations because of the
coronavirus Georgia reported major
problems with new voting machines and a
shortage of poll workers at O'Keefe is
covering campaign 2020 ad what happened
and can they fix it before November I
keep hearing it was a hot mess
good morning to you it's certainly one
way to put it Gail yes and that is
certainly the hope that it gets cleaned
up by November Georgia of course a place
Democrats hope to make a presidential
battleground in the fall the issues they
had there basically center around the
coronavirus longtime poll workers didn't
want to show up out of health concerns
the new ones that did didn't know how to
operate new voting machines and so it
led to long lines like this video shows
us thousands waited for hours to cast
their ballots the Secretary of State's
office is blaming some County officials
mostly in the Atlanta area because of
these conditions and some voters
expressed outrage especially given that
Georgia has a history of voter
suppression I don't think it's the new
machines I do think that there is
systematic disenfranchisement of
specific communities now five states
held primaries yesterday but it was what
happened in Nevada in Georgia with
delays that stretched into last night
that give great big concern to election
officials nationwide the pandemic is
just causing this you have to have fewer
voting sites potentially to control
crowds there will be long lines and
there's concern that there will be a big
strain on the vote by mail or absentee
system Tony election day might turn into
election weeks as it takes a while
potentially in some places to count up
the balance yeah and I hear you but the
right to vote is fundamental we've got
to find a way to make sure people can
exercise it and thank you very much